thank you for joining us and merry
christmas eve i'm john langler we
certainly hope you are enjoying the
holiday
safely right now as we head into the
holiday weekend
and let's get things started with a look
at your christmas weather and who better
than nate tannenbaum and as a look
outside it's a bit cloudy outside right
now oh for sure your most accurate
weather now forecast and john
this is about as wintry as it gets here
in las vegas how about this incredible
live picture
do you know where this is have you seen
this before the rock rink of course
downtown downtown summerlin from our
camera on top of the red rock resort yes
there is ice skating in las vegas
obviously
that is man-made ice but that is the
real deal let's check out the
temperature zone it's going to remain
well below normal and much cooler we're
talking about a reading of 52 degrees at
mccarran airport at this hour now we are
going to check in
with your neighborhoods we don't have as
much wind as we did the past couple of
days
we're also going to talk about well
let's go ahead and talk about it right
now the situation
up on mount charleston if you're
thinking of heading up to mount
charleston
well this is what you need to do you
need to be very careful because there's
little to no snow
expected up on mount charleston we're
talking about
clark county putting out a tweet saying
please do not go
up there this is video from last year
so there is some snow if you're looking
to head up there here's what we're
talking about for the ski area you can't
just go up there on the spur of the
moment reservations are now required
not only to go seeing but just to park
up there as for the rest of the mountain
including
kyle canyon that tweet this morning
saying that with little snow
anybody playing or even walking around
up there could damage the vegetation
so they want you to wait until there's
more snow and john that
could happen over the next few days
we'll talk about that in the seven-day
forecast in a few minutes